hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and today we're talking about
economics economics has always seemed
like a funny field to me I mean the one
hand it can be extremely mathematical
precise rigorous theorems are proven on
the other hand it's extraordinarily
relevant to the messiness of everyday
life and there's this ongoing tension
between the pristine mathematics and the
messiness of reality furthermore in the
United States at least right now people
are wondering about what kind of
economics we should have of course
capitalism I don't think it's possible
to deny the capitalism has done good
things we have had enormous growth over
the last several hundred years on the
other hand it's also impossible to deny
that unchecked capitalism can be
extremely deleterious we need a social
safety net etc some people even here in
the US are looking at controlled
economies like they have in China with a
little bit of envy there's a lot to be
skeptical about in the economic
performance of the US right now on the
one hand the stock market and GDP is
growing on the other hand we have more
inequality than we've had in a long time
on the one hand unemployment is low but
on the other hand there's a lack of
really good jobs it's easy to get a job
but not one that really earns you a
living wage so some people are beginning
to question the fundamental truths of
received economics today I'm talking to
Suresh Naidu who is a professor of
economics and international affairs at
Columbia University as well as external
professor at Santa Fe Institute Suresh
is not a bomb thrower he's not trying to
overthrow the system or anything but
he's very interested in the relationship
of economics to other big-picture
questions about how societies function
does democracy promote growth what was
the economic influence of slavery can we
have equitable economic growth is it
possible to have booming economic growth
while we still have equality and still
take care of the people who are not
doing well in our society so go into
questions about capitalism socialism
what's been good questions about the
labor market and inflation and monopsony
as well as monopolies it's a fast
little intro to a whole bunch of big
topics for people who are not experts in
economics including myself
remember the check out our webpage at
preposterous universe calm / - cape one
of the things you have to remember is
that we have show notes for every
episode so you can find links to things
so for example in today's episodes with
suresh we're talking about a textbook
that he and many other collaborators
have been working on an openly available
textbook in economics you can find a
link to that on the webpage so with that
let's go
[Music]
Suresh Naidu welcome to mindscape
podcast thanks for having me I've been
on record as saying that I want to have
more economics on the podcast I talked
about lots of things that's okay there's
a lot there but it's a little bit
intimidating I decided it's intimidating
because what I do for a living you know
dark matter the origin of the universe
it doesn't affect people's daily lives
right their daily bread their jobs etc
but economics is relentlessly practical
in some way so so much economics is not
the kind of high abstract theoretical
stuff that I love so much but really
down-to-earth trade and markets and and
labor and things what what is the
division of labor
inside economics like that is an
accurate representation of my so so I
would say that like economics does have
certain parts of it that are actually
really are kind of about describing big
impersonal forces that wind up
constraining or shaping what we what our
everyday lives look like in the much in
the same way that you know gravity or
ecology or you know atmospheric pressure
is a real thing in our lives and we
don't necessarily understand it all but
what physics and the rigorous study
these things do is let you understand
these forces that are just really
important in your life and then you know
and I think many physicists also think
this that one of the things you learn
when you understand these forces that
you get sort of some insight into what
are the tools for manipulating them
manipulating them what are the
constraints on those tools what are the
orders of magnitude of scale that you
can like humans can reasonably move with
what kinds of with what kinds of
instruments and so I would say it's a
it's at that level of abstraction it's
very similar like there's a bunch of
things in economics that are about
describing patterns of global trade
macroeconomic forces that are really
imporant of the aggregated decisions of
billions of people showing up but then
one of the benefits of understanding
that is that you then understand how
like okay well what is the minimum wage
going to do or what can central banks do
with the interest rate and
what are the places that you have these
touch points that you can push a lever
or do something and maybe make things a
little bit better and so that I think
it's you know not so far away I don't
think well yeah that's what I'm thinking
is there the economics equivalent by the
way do you say economics or economics
economics I it depends what country
there is there the equivalent of you
know string theorists or mathematical
physicists who never look at data
whatsoever like never apply this stuff
to the real world are there purely big
brain economists who just work out
general principles or does basically
everyone dip their fingers into the
muddy waters of reality I mean you must
know the answer yeah so I mean as you
know as you probably know like the whole
20th century of economics was dominated
by basically uh brilliant
mathematical theorists yeah everyone
from Kenneth arrow who was a founder of
SFI I have the Santa Fe Institute and
people like Paul Samuelson and just just
people whose entire lens on the world
was billing these incredibly elegant
theories that would capture some very
deep fundamental truths about the way
markets work tour the way you know
political institutions could work or
just just tools for understanding what
it meant to have supply and demand equal
to each other so and for I would say
overwhelmingly for the 20th century
economics was in this world where what
it meant to do good economics was you
built mathematical models and what it
meant if you weren't a really good
mathematical theorist is that then you
went off and like didn't P Racal work
and looked at the world and but I do you
think so not only is there that
distinction in economics but it's the
same status hierarchy it was yeah you
know there's a axellian hundred old
never pronounce his name but he had an
article about like life among the e cons
where he kind of takes like an
anthropological lens to the to the
economists and sort of say you know they
have their their fetishes they're called
models and like that you know you have
the highest caste group who are like the
manipulators and creators of these
models and
and so that was really like economics I
think in the in the in the 20th century
and then I think what has been a slow
but but I think positive development is
that kind of social scientific data
became our microscope and just made it
that the starting in like the 60s than
things even with the rise of like labor
market data like the current population
survey like the individual files of the
Census and the computational power to
process them it became now a world where
you really at not at wasn't enough to
just have a kind of cute idea about how
this theoretical force might work you
actually had to sort of provide some
evidence that it mattered and it also
wasn't enough to just sort of say well
supply equal demand and that that would
obviously answer all these all of these
questions because you know it became
like something that we actually had to
look at well how important are these
some supply and demand forces relative
to the background noise that's just
going on and everything in society and
all these other things
maybe we're mathematically right but
quantitatively small and that becomes
something that we start to look at so
there's both a measurement angle of the
rise of government surveys there's a way
in which like the operations of
government themselves generates so much
data running a UI system Social Security
you know administering in in in European
countries administering like corporatist
wage setting between unions and firms
it's just like as those processes became
more routinized in bureaucratic they
generated a huge volume of data that was
then also kind of a great social science
microscope so it's the big data era
babies a big data it's a bit it's a big
data era I would say it like it's a
little bit I'm a you know in the style
of economics that I sort of come out of
we were always using the big the biggest
data data sets you could get your hands
on and yes some things have changed with
with with with big data but in some ways
like a lot of the principles that we had
with small data
just it's just a computational problem
it's not a conceptual problem
and yeah and I want to say an important
part of that is I kind of a I think also
since the late 90s has been like a real
attention to what we'd say is causality
and causal identification oh look so
that it wasn't enough to so basically
there was a lot of sort of shoddy work
around correlations and saying oh see
this correlation shows that this theory
is correct but never not not nearly as
much of the kind of paying attention to
looking at the parts of the world that
look like they're generating natural
experiments or that there's like where
something is just shifted all of a
sudden and then that's like a
particularly clean test of a theory and
so basically the rise of this kind of
causal causal revolution in economics
really sort of you know we also changed
how we how we use data so that we really
became attended attentive that you
couldn't just like mine a dataset and
look for whatever correlations that you
wanted you got to really commit to a
design that was like okay here's a
control group here's a treatment group
let's look at the difference and make
sure that those things are comparable on
every other dimension I'm sure this is a
very unfair question but is there one
big lesson that has been learned since
we have been paying attention these big
datasets and causality and things like
that or is it many fiddle lessons um I'd
say there's a couple of big lessons but
what you're definite what you all think
of as big depends on what you kind of
care about the world so like one thing
that's kind of been you know a lot of
papers got written on and kind of like
answer the question was like what's the
rate of return to a year of schooling
and and basically you know 15 years of
trying to estimate that using all sorts
of clever things about lotteries and
distance universities I'm trying to get
this kind of experimental experimental
variation generates you know we roughly
get a ballpark number between nine and
twelve percent so that's that's actual
percent in in like in terms of like just
salaries yeah another one though that
sorry and that's and that was a
difficult thing because of course
education is correlated with a whole
bunch of school and go schools correlate
with your ability dance yeah and your
parents and your parents income and all
this stuff and so finding places where
you could actually say no sending this
person to school generated their
increase their earnings by twelve
percent I think that's a result and we
kind of have that that's and is that
elementary school high school college
grads tell me this is the places that we
have the it's it's it's a reasonably
stable I think twelve percent is in in
the high school to college range so
that's that's sort of where at least my
familiarity with that evidence kind of
lives but it serves how that was one of
the as like a victory in in labor
economics is that we sort of know that
like there's like a positive rate of
return schooling stay in school yeah the
other although not at any price so there
is it's only twelve percent the other
thing I mean which I'm happy to go into
because I know a lot about it is is like
this endless debates on the minimum wage
and and how you know basically this this
almost as long as it's been a minimum
wage economists have argued about
whether or not it on that cost jobs and
and you know I wouldn't say that it's
like a hundred percent settled now but I
think it's like 80 to 95 percent settled
now she's super good and super zen he
knows I might get overturned like we
might get a whole new wave of studies
that just flip this around well let's
see particularly the minimum wage it
starts at some point it's gonna if you
just keep ratcheting up the minimum wage
I think at some point you start to see
disemployment effects but but I think
one of the other successes of this kind
of causal identification turn has been
kind of really getting clean estimates
of like the lack of okay let's suppose
let's suppose them in a wage does kill
jobs if it's if it does it's a very
small number well that's not the result
is that the minimum wage roughly
speaking doesn't kill job doesn't kill
very many jobs it's not close
unemployment yeah and you know so if it
yeah so it you know
imagine that like a 10% increase in the
minimum wage will cost no more than like
0.1% of jobs that's is the kind of
estimates we're after and that is
something that's incredibly cuts to the
core so many people's priors about what
markets are like and you know cuz if
supply is equal to demand and then you
impose a minimum wage then that has to
reduce employment it's just what the
craft says well I mean just to put that
in other words saying the same thing if
employees cost more money you're gonna
have less of them yeah that's yeah it's
like in Gary Becker I think literally
said this it's like gravity goes the
wrong way and and but but I think one of
the useful things about this
transformation of economics into kind of
a much more empirical much more and what
we call identification based based
discipline has been that we are able to
take things that were just kind of
somewhat ideological articles of faith
about how markets must work and just
yeah and find that yeah it often in lots
of markets supply does equal demand and
and in some markets it's more
complicated I want to pause to talk
about joy bird furniture because if
there's one thing we know about
mindscape listeners they have style and
taste and when it comes time to buy
furniture the stuff that is out there
might not match your unique sense of
style
so with joy bird you can create the kind
of style and furniture that you want you
can customize it you can bring your
vision to life with over 50 fabric and
leather options three different shades
of wood and over 250 unique silhouettes
you have leather you have velvet and you
also have a range of kid-friendly and
pet friendly upholstery options plus a
protection plan to keep the pieces
looking as great as the day they come
into your home don't let me forget that
there's a 365-day home trial so you can
sit on it
sleep on it break it in if you don't
love your joy bird you can return it so
create furniture that matches your own
fearless style at joy bird calm / mind
scape see how joy bird can help
make your dream space a reality today at
joy Bird calm / mindscape
that will get you an exclusive offer for
25% off your first order by using the
code mindscape I get that impression
from not only reading your stuff but
other people that economists know the
following that in econ 101 we treat we
teach you that markets are the best in
supply and demand control everything and
then in econ 102 in every subsequent
course all we talk about is how the
market fails and how we had to fix it
yeah and then I mean there's also econ 3
which is like how the government is
attempting to fix them also also then
fail and and then there's like econ 4
which is how like you actually in order
to fix the government failures you might
actually need a specific set of iike of
market failures to like anyway so so we
can keep going but but I think that's
that's roughly roughly right up for
first class yeah I mean so if our
intuition about why the minimum wage
should cause unemployment is wrong
what's right what have should we think
about the minimum wage so I think this
comes to the the other thing too that's
I want to talk about which is just like
well what deliver markets actually
actually look like and they look like a
world in which particularly at the at
the bottom end in which employers are
not taking the market wage is given
where they have some leeway to choose
wages because they have to manage
because workers don't have perfect
turnover across a jobs only was a
different way so when I cut my wage by
10 percent as an employer what fraction
of my workers disappears in the next say
1 2 3 years and you know standard
economic theory would say a hundred
percent everyone has to leave
instantaneously and it would you know a
better job I get a better job elsewhere
but what you see in the data when you
actually get those kinds of experiments
it's roughly like 30 percent which is
not zero so it's like the market forces
are are there yeah but it's also not in
and it's also not like everyone
immediately it's like 30 percent over a
year it takes a while and so what that
means is that employers have some
discretion because they can be like ok I
can pick a wage that's maybe a little
bit lower than I'd be then I
be willing I might be willing to pay
because I'll save on payroll
I might have to endure a little bit of
higher turnover but it's worth it to me
in exchange for what I can save on on
payroll and so then if employers are
then kind of trading off this wages and
turnover which is very intuitive if you
look at any HR textbook these kind of
what they tell you so what you know it's
like you're worried about turnover you
should think about the wage you're
setting then that means that one of the
things that when that happens when the
minimum wage goes up is that you kind of
get you're forced to raise a higher wage
and so you get lower turnover as a
result and then then that like offsets
any like additional cost of labor that
you might have faced with it though
they'll face from the additional minimum
wage so you can think of it this way
like and there's a paper that finds this
oh sorry this yeah that was backwards
from what we were just talking about so
you were just saying if you lower the
wages people would leave but they don't
and now you're saying if you raise the
wages the employers won't go sorry so
you're starting from a from a place
where employers have set the wage yeah
such that they're enduring a given level
turnover and they're paying a low wage
huh and so then imagine that a wage
comes in and like forces them to pay a
higher wage right and so then they're
like well now they have to take that
higher wage but as a as kind of a
byproduct they get lower turnover okay
yeah and so that's why you don't see
necessarily so many jobs getting
destroyed is because there's this
offsetting force of the lower turnover
and they were willing to pay that much
all along as well no it's costing them
profits it's costing profits and they're
passing along some of it to consumers
for sure okay all right so both of those
things happen but I think still loose
supply and demand there's yeah there's
still like but one of the things you
don't see is this immediate cost in jobs
yeah okay because of this like kind of
offset in in decreased turnover and so
to where what you actually see when you
can see recruits and quits kind of
separately is that you'll see that when
you there's a paper that looked at this
in the US that that found that like new
hiring Falls but separations fall the
exact same amount and so that's why use
kind of a net wash so you hire fewer new
workers but your existing workers don't
quit nearly as much and so you don't
shrink you know
wrong planet so in both cases in the
fact that the workers don't leave
immediately if their wages are lowered
and the fact that the employers don't
hire far fewer people if the minimum
wage comes in there's sort of a
stickiness or a friction in sort of
physics terms right like there's an
ideal system where things work a certain
way but the world is far from ideal yeah
let's talk about that I mean so I feel
like that is often how we're taught
economics which is that the perfectly
competitive frictionless world is
analogous to the ideal-gas it's like
this is the thing that you know without
any other information you should think
that it looks like this and then you
bolt things onto this apparatus in order
to make it look more like reality yeah
and so I'm of mixed minds about that I'm
like yes that's a pretty powerful way to
work partly because that perfect
competition thing comes with a bunch of
like mathematical things that make it
really tractable and make it like and
you can you can you can communicate it
very easily to other economist everyone
knows what it looks like so so it is
very powerful but for certain things
it's also like terribly misleading and
such that and particularly around I mean
I guess this is just my my hobby horse
is that particularly around things
around the labor market but I would also
say like the land market and the credit
market like these markets where there's
lots of these gets complicated that the
perfect competition assumption does more
violence to the reality ok then might be
acceptable and we don't have a we don't
yet have a benchmark for that's a that's
a substitute for that frictionless world
so we're still kind of hovering around
it but I feel like there's a there's if
you looked at that theoretical models
now that are even trying to be
quantitatively made more accurate
resemble the real world they have to
adopt as baseline measures departures
from that frictionless world so let me
give you a concrete example if you want
a world in which there's any kind of
role for monetary policy for example
from the central bank
you need a world in which prices are
sort of sticky and so to get just like
as a first pass these are what are
called
you Keynesian kind of kind of models is
that you need models where it's we're
not all firms can adjust all their
prices instantaneously and so there's
like a couple of tricks for getting that
one is like a monopolistic competition
and like a staggered price setting and
that's that's one modeling trick that is
kind of becomes almost another benchmark
in all of the models that need to talk
about kind of monetary policy because
it's really hard to get a role for
monetary policy in a model that doesn't
have that kind of like friction so
there's like one sort of mini canonical
model that that that talks about that
let me give you another example and it
was sorry but the idea is that I mean
your your underlying claim is that the
very idea of a frictionless model being
the good starting point is it's so far
away from reality that it's just not
even a good starting it's not even a
good starting point or I wonder about it
like okay yeah so I blame Galileo for
all this by the way yeah well you know
Galileo overturned Aristotelian physics
you know two objects he says will
actually fall at the same rate and you
can do an experiment and drop a rock and
a feather and they don't fold the same
right and I think the Galileo gets
credit for the first one to say but they
would burn for air resistance right and
sort of he sort of set the paradigm of
physics that let's ignore as much as we
can ignore and then put everything back
in later that's very very interesting I
hadn't heard it dated back to Galileo
I'm sure there's a bit of you know
selection effect of giving credit to
famous people but you know he was
synthesizing things that other people
did but I think that that paradigm of
imagining a world without friction
without dissipation and so forth and
then you can build on that to get the
real world
I think Galileo gets as much credit for
interesting that's very interesting but
there's no reason why it has to work
where things are strongly coupled to
nonlinear like they are in a economic
yeah or and it's also like it kind of
feels like it should depend on the
problem that you're trying to solve like
for for some problems air resistance is
the thing that you actually care about
exactly there's a whole other limit
where you're moving through molasses not
air yeah start by assuming it's
frictionless so so that's at least how I
think about it night also one point out
there's like lots of ways in which this
frictionless world it's not just a
theoretical construct it gets embedded
into how do we construct various
measures of national income and and in
government statistics construction
there's like a surprising amount of kind
of folk theorizing that goes into even
like core economic measurement that
you're always like is that we really
believe that that's and so I just want
to like flag that it's not purely
theoretical things it matters for how we
actually measure the world well in
closely related to this minimum wage
question is the monopsony monopolization
which is i just gave you the short
version we can use the technical term
here yes it's a useful one I'm sure that
everyone's heard of monopolies yeah
where there's one company that has all
the products yeah so what's monopsony so
so first let me clarify says that
monopoly monopoly power I guess is kind
of just considered you know it's just
that you have some ability to set the
price so that you don't have to take the
market prices given you can instead have
some control over what price you set
okay so you're not if you change the
price a little bit you don't lose all of
your customers immediately it's again
like that thirty percent right thing you
lose some but not everyone and so that's
kind of the flip the monopsony is
basically the flip side of that for the
labor market where you think about wages
you know instead of a firm having to
take the market wages given it it
instead has some discretion to set the
wage so let me give you some and so
that's this like and one of the things
when they do have this discretion they
can they can manage it and and say yeah
you know I'm gonna pay a little bit of a
lower wage and accept the additional
turnover and that that same same thing I
explained a little bit a little bit
earlier but let me just give like some
very concrete sort of real-world bonus
for this so for example you can go
online you can find these leaked slides
from Walmart's HR program a talk most
sam's club and like how they set pay and
so it turns out one of the things that's
very interesting in that is that they
talk about how if you actually if a
sam's club needs to set a wage that's
really different from the national wage
policy they need to apply to Bentonville
Arkansas for a special exemption okay
so that suggests that you know that's
the headquarter headquarters yes and so
that suggests that it's not the case
that every Walmart has to like exactly
pay the wage in that in that labor
market that's in fact the national wage
policy another paper by a co-author of
mine and his co-authors Dube Giuliano
and Leonard was looking at this national
retailer that basically had a policy
that gave you a raise that that depended
very discontinuously on your previous
wage so if you have if you're making
like one penny over some threshold you
were like got a very different raise
than if you were making one penny below
okay and so what you can do is look to
see what happens to quits
among those well like do workers
differentially leave just around that
based on the change in the raise that
they got turns out not that many left
when they didn't get the same raise
relative to those that did suggesting
again that like there's there's again
there's not just a huge responsiveness
to the wage in the labor market but I
think what's also evidence about this is
also evidence for is that you know the
very fact that you can have this like
weirdo wage raise policy where you had
all these like discontinuities in it is
not the kind of thing that you think
that comes out of like a smooth market
taking system where you would just have
to naturally it would look like it would
look like wages it would look like
airline prices we'd have lots of round
numbers and things would be like I much
smoother distribution but the fact that
when you look at a wage policy and you
see all this like bunching and kinking
and all of this stuff suggests that
there's a real like room for human
decision making then isn't there also an
information problem I mean we have the
social more that we don't ask each other
what we're getting as a salary right
yeah that certainly helps the people
setting salaries it does it doesn't
there's some very interesting studies on
this by the way I should flag you know
there's been the great campaign by
co-worker org that's been to make these
like kind of online spreadsheets where
workplaces can like share their their
their salaries and that's become like an
important like kind of labor organizing
tool I've actually seen that for science
journalists with you know what magazine
oh yeah that's great
yeah there
they're not publicly available but their
share yeah yeah so that's that's kind of
that's exactly like creating information
about what wages are and there's also
this kind of a great study done by these
professors at UC Berkeley so if you're a
Berkeley wages are public for a public
employer and so what they did is they
actually randomized showing some workers
a link to the pay of their co-workers
and and others not and look to see the
job search and quit behavior of those
that got the ability to compare their
wages to their their their their peers
and they find that those that are making
below what their peers are making are
more likely to leave a lot more okay
information is power
yes so I just think that that's like
kind of some some some immediate
evidence that the labor market doesn't
look like the market for chairs and
there's not like this law of one price
and another piece of evidence that sort
of come out from this big air of big
data is this availability of matched
worker firm data that where you can see
like the same worker being employed by
different firms over time and you can
see how much of their wage changes
depending on what firm that they're at
at versus who they are so you can
imagine if the labor market was totally
frictionless the wage would just depend
on you not which firm you were at
because all firms should be in the same
labor market you have an intrinsic worth
and they pay it and they pay it yeah
exactly it's like your human capital
captures this is priced and every every
company has to pay the same price for
that so but what you in fact see is that
there's a considerable movement of
individual workers wages so something
between fifteen and twenty percent of
the wage variation that we see is
explained by the firm that you're at not
just you're who you are and so that
suggested given this like reasonably
important role for firms that again
there's like this kind of room for all
these frictions because that's that's
that's a deviation so I guess I don't
note that I don't know if there's an
analog in physics for the kind of person
that's really obsessed with the
frictions the kind of person that's
really into the ideal and in the
frictionless model right I mean you have
to be to some people you have to do that
you've probably heard of peloton it
a game-changing cardio workout that you
can do in the comfort of your own home
and now there's a new way that you can
overcome that barrier to getting it done
with a 30 day home trial there's free
pickup and full refund so if you're
interested in possibly seeing what life
is like with a peloton bike in your home
you can try it out and see what you
think free for 30-days
peloton is super convenient you can use
the bike whenever you want there's a
great variety of workouts available
there can be live motivation right you
can have a live class with a world-class
instructor or you can just do it on your
own time one membership can have
profiles for the whole home so if it's
not just you if there's other people
who'll be working out you can track your
progress differently you can have
different preferences and so forth so
try it yourself learn more about the
30-day home trial at 1 peloton calm
that's oh and E PE l OT om calm and get
$100 off accessories with the purchase
of the peloton bike if you use the promo
code mindscape that's one peloton calm
and use promo code mindscape to get
started
restrictions apply but so this this
leads into the real world question of
low wage jobs right there's there's been
a lot less of rebounding in the low wage
sector than the high wage sector since
the financial crisis if I understand
correctly and some people have blamed
automation other people have blamed
globalization and this sort of labor
market sickness is a different
explanation yes yes so I want to be
clear that like a bunch of those other a
bunch of the explanations do you have
like I'm not gonna deny the traders
China has had a huge effect on American
jobs and that's like a big that is a big
factor Automation I think it's a little
bit premature I don't know that we have
like really amazing evidence that
automation has really leveled American
employment yang is very worried about it
well yes but I feel like it's it's kind
of I feel like this is fantasy that like
American capitalism goes through every
like couple of generations is like in
the sixties it's like the robots are
coming
and well it seems to be like a perpetual
belief that jobs will disappear because
of automation yeah it always seems to be
true that other jobs pop up but maybe
that doesn't last right and you know who
knows I I don't know if that's like an
iron law or like that that just might be
a law insofar as there's things that
humans have a comparative advantage in
relative to machines but I do want to
suggest that there's a way in which the
you know and we also want to flag that
we're currently at like record low
unemployment like kind of insanely low
you know unemployment hot hot labor
market and yet we're seeing that it's
really difficult to pick up increases in
wages in this period of which no one
goes against our intuition from econ 101
yes exactly and that it goes it also
points against some of the automation
and trade stories because it's like a
lot of those stories were the main thing
going on then you would expect it's also
you see it show up in unemployment as
well as wages yeah well if it's oh but
if you have really low unemployment but
but you're seeing you know low wage
growth is kind of like what brings you
to like kind of a what's a different
category of explanation and so I don't
want to say that monopsony is like the
the only or main thing going on here I
don't know I do think it is interesting
that one of the a lot of the forces that
have counter veiled monopsony you have
just been in slow decline so like Union
things so a lot of the things that took
the wage setting power out of the hands
of firms have just like over fifty
seventy years have just declined and and
because of changes in government policy
or just I would say some of it is
changing government policy some of it as
these other technology and trade things
so you can imagine a big chunk of the
effect of trade is via hammering Union
manufacturing jobs yeah and you know
part of them were like relocating to
right-to-work the states and that got
hastened by it by but by globalization
and once you have more and more of
manufacturing for those who don't know
right-to-work is basically like right to
not be in union right and and so
just you know between and both like
relentless government hostility to
unions particularly since like the 1970s
so you can think of those two things
happening together and so that this this
erosion of this institution that pushed
back against that sort of curbed
monopsony but also made us think that it
wasn't a big problem
so I which is sort of it's a which is an
interesting history of thought kind of
thing that like in the 1940s and 50s
labor economists who are not like the
high priests of mathematical theory but
these were the people that were working
you know there were professors at like
Harvard and Princeton and and Berkeley
and they were also employed in the
National War labor board to like
involved in wage setting involved in
Union firm negotiations and they very
much had the idea that the labor market
when it was not regulated looked like
monopsony okay and that in that firm
it's an old idea exactly I didn't invent
it
by no means and it was not invented in
the last twenty years it's like John
Robinson who's in my own mind the
greatest economist of the 20th century I
just want to say that so that more
people look up who she is and she's a
really interesting when was she working
so in the nineteen thirties and forties
and fifties and sixties seventies so so
she was one of Keynes's compatriots in
Cambridge and and one of the people in
that circle of a British British
economics and like the mid-century and
so she comes up with it she's also one
of these economists that partly because
of who she is and stuff that's like
always like arguing with the Marxists
and so it takes their ideas very
seriously but it's like like are
destructive or you can't you can kind of
see monopsony is like kind of a sort of
somewhat of a genesis of that coming out
of some of those some of those
conversations and and and when labor
when labor economists heard about this
theoretical thing they were like yeah
that's that's totally right and and you
know so there's a great quote I love
from this paper by Clark Kerr who was a
labor economist in 1950 which is like
yes yes yes this theory of like what he
called it natural competition but
monopsonistic competition it might be
relevant for like less I fail
Marcus but the labor markets of the
future are going to be administered and
unionized and so this kind of an obscene
thing isn't really a relevant object of
study because we're where we're headed
to a world where everyone's going to be
in a union so the workers would prevent
yes basically yes and so so he might
have got the effect of unionization on
monopsony right but he got the time
trend of unionization totally wrong yes
and so so I think that that that that's
an interesting history of thought partly
but also because those those old what
they were called institutionalist labor
economists really got the idea that
there is kind of a considerable amount
of discretion that firms have and wage
setting that it wasn't just like this
frictionless supply and demand they had
this idea that there was like a band of
wages that you know wages could be set
around in this band and that there was
considerable leeway within that band so
that was like a way of adding frictions
hysteresis or something yeah yeah so so
I think yeah so how did not sure how I
got back to the to those but I think
this point that that the labor market is
a particularly a place where these
frictions are important and so if you
really kind of care about studying low
wages and labor market outcomes you kind
of need to depart from the frictionless
model to get it right and it's my vague
feeling correct that organized labor has
just been declining in power for decades
yes yeah absolutely
it takes a particularly sharp downturn
and in the early 80s and summer that's
the eighty one recession something that
is just generic employer like employer
hasta it's something that's actually
paper i working on is kind of just
trying to document this change in norms
that just seems like this like all of a
sudden this tip in norms among employers
where before they were kind of playing
softball with with unions I'd be like
okay well you know you can go out on
strike we won't fire you even though
they had all kinds of legal powers to
fight unions with more vigor they didn't
use them just because of the norms
against them and then that just flips
in the 70s they all of a sudden become
like all right truce is off we're now
gonna fire workers during strikes and
fill them with replace them with
permanent permanent replacements and the
Reagan administration like a green light
to jumpstart that so I think that's all
part of the the it's part of the sauce
of what's going on I don't know that
anything I mean there's also structural
ways in which American and British and
Australian unions are organized that
makes it hard to imagine how they could
come back in the form that they existed
because they're organized on like an
enterprise basis rather than on a whole
labor market basis so in Europe you know
unions are sector-wide and they got
everyone's in them and or everyone's at
least covered by them and in the u.s.
it's been this like firm by firm kind of
organizing model and that's just a
really uphill battle for unions so so I
don't know what the I don't know that
unions are going to come back in the
form that they look like I do think
something like them needs to come back
to sort of if something that curbs the
use of monopoly power by firms needs to
like well I'm gonna ask is that your
prescription is there a best way to
fight against this monopsony power yeah
so I think I do think that like some
sort of way of workers getting a
substantial voice in how wages are set
and collectively and and what's
important about like it's difficult for
the government to do it so the
government can impose a minimum wage but
one of the things that the government
can't know is exactly what's the a
what's the mix of wages and benefits
that workers want be how much of that
mix of whatever workers want are
consistent with the firm's business
model and like them making profits so
it's one reason why I like kind of
unions are kind of a better solution
than government regulation and lots of
places because they can customize the
terms of a collective bargain
agreement to the particular needs of
that workplace and those workers so it's
still the free market it's just there's
some organization on one side yeah so
you can think of it as the fruit I don't
know I feel like most people that would
say this the free market would say well
if you have to negotiate collectively
then it's not free but you kind of want
it to be collective because you need
that kind of balance of bargaining power
on both sides it can it has to be all
the workers at once I mean maybe there's
another term for it's it's not the
government doing it it's not the
government doing it it's decentralized I
would say it's it's a it's decentralized
and it's bottom-up right but I'm not and
but it's not free-market mindscape
listeners love to learn but there's not
enough mindscape to fill the day frankly
so you might want to consider the great
courses plus this is a streaming service
that gets you college-level courses
directly to your home whether it's your
laptop your mobile device or whatever
you'll have access to the best
professors from the best universities in
the world with courses that cover all
sorts of different topics from history
to languages to music to of course
science there's a wonderful course
called black holes tides and curved
space-time understanding gravity gravity
from Isaac Newton to Albert Einstein and
beyond I have my own courses that I've
done on the Higgs boson on time on dark
matter dark energy so you can unlock the
world of knowledge with the great
courses plus for mindscape listeners you
can get a full month unlimited access
for free if you sign up today using a
special URL go to the great courses
plus.com slash mindscape that's th e
great courses PLU s calm slash mindscape
for a full month of college courses all
over the map for absolutely free goodies
this raises a whole bunch of deeper
things we've successfully covered what I
wanted to be the second half of the
interview in the first half so that's
good that's fine we've got the first
half that's how we roll here in
mindscape we just follow the flow of the
river I mean the free market capitalism
how do you feel about these things how
should we feel about these things let's
be big picture and ask you know
certainly there's been enormous
successes there's been dramatic failures
if you
that there are people who are very very
Pro free market who love to bring up
spectacular failures of central planning
and there are flower plants and there's
exactly the opposite there are people
very anti free-market who love to bring
up the spectacular failures of
capitalism and there's fewer people sort
of talking to people who are very we're
close to them but slightly different you
know across what device do you have a
big opinion about this stuff or is the
does the economics profession have big
opinions
yeah no way the economics profession
does not I think it's almost as like
almost like a condition of membership is
not allowed to have an opinion about
capitalism well yeah generally it's like
pro but like it's the kind of thing that
like oh we're trying to be scientific so
as like cosmologists being asked about
the existence of god yes so okay so a
couple of things one is no one should
deny that like the success of capitalism
in raising material standards of living
has been kind of amazing and a world
historical break and you know cosmos
will easy another SFI professor has a
great line which is like the singularity
already happened and it was the
Industrial Revolution and we basically
like you know let these eldritch forces
loose and one of those is kind of
letting people buy and sell stuff out of
arm's length transactions and that kind
of very being a really great way to
ordinate people's wants over very very
distances people can look online there's
this charming short video with you in it
where you're complaining about the lack
of Wi-Fi on the train in London and then
you go well but then again 800 years ago
they were you know dying of dysentery
and eating gruel exactly exactly so
that's part of this textbook project
which we should talk about um so so and
so that's why like when what irritates
me to no end is when anti capitalists
sort of somehow pretend that it was
better before capitalist so I've no
sympathy for that argument
what an argument I do have some sympathy
for is that you know your that's not the
right counterfactual the counterfactual
we should always be thinking about is
how does it performing relative to what
some other thing that we could have and
so looking to the past doesn't generate
the right counterfactual what you want
to think about is another possible
future and are there do there exist
other like economic organizations ways
of organizing the economy that given the
technologies that we have that might
actually be like a better fit and might
result in more human flourishing less
inequality more environmental
sustainability all of these good things
that we want could we do better and I
feel like we don't do ourselves a lot of
favors by pretending that the thing that
we've got is the best that it could
possibly be and a friend of mine Glen
Juana says it's like it's like it's like
an engineer looking at the Telegraph and
thinking this has got to be the best way
to communicate guys like yeah we've got
it it says and so so we should as social
scientists as citizens be thinking about
doing things better and so some of that
is just policy fixes within the orbit of
capitalism and we can talk about lots of
those and that's things like healthcare
and like like antitrust and like minimum
wages and some of them might involve
like things that are kind of strike more
to the core of what makes capitalism
distinctive which you can think of this
like making private property a little
bit more of an elastic concept so you
can imagine in an economy where the
biggest resources are like ideas that
putting those in the shackles of private
ownership and in patents and in monopoly
rights is kind of not necessarily doing
ourselves the best giving ourselves the
best chance of success well and these
days when you can patent or copyright
genes or algorithms and things like that
it seems bizarre to me it seems to me
that maybe that's exactly what you're
saying it's not a comfortable fit where
yes to these concepts that were brought
up in the context of you know acting
yeah yeah or even like trading widgets
and and that when you have these goods
that are like you know as simple as
cause almost like fugitive resources
they're like a high fixed cost zero
marginal cost kinds of goods that
shackling them with the institutions of
capitalism you know maybe maybe it's not
a great fit and then other people that
are Pro capitalists will say yes that's
what's been said at every technological
change is that is that capitalism is no
longer a good fit and what you'll always
see is that it winds up sort of still
doing a better job than any other system
so I mean because private property and
property rights are like the central
tenant they're definitely like a big
part of it um I mean I do think let's
let's just be a little pro capitalist
for a second um it's I think of it as a
search strategy right you know in some
way capitalism is a way to find a
certain kind of equilibrium that has
good properties people are innovative
they try to do better they have
incentives pointing in the right
direction you know what is your pro
capitalist sales pitch for someone who's
never heard of it I think that's right I
think it's like the idea that that you
the way that you get prestige and status
and material resources in capitalism is
by making things that other people want
to buy yeah and that's a real break from
like how human history did it before
which was like you killed lots of people
or like or you conquered lots of
territory or something and so so the a
real institutional break is making the
basis of social reward providing useful
things to like anonymous strangers so
it's more of a win-win it's more of a
win-win and so then for yourself by
doing things and if that's behind it I
mean if you put it abstractly like that
it's like what a great door thing I
think the limitations is that of that is
that like there's other things that you
can do that are really profitable under
capitalism that don't involve making
useful things for other people well I
want to just sort of talk about the term
rent seeking yeah cuz it's used as sort
of an epithet but I think probably most
people on the street were like you know
well yeah people own property and they
rent it let's deal with that so so we
should back up and and define concepts
so
technically in economics is just defined
as like a payment for something above
and beyond its next-best its payment
that it would guess and there's next
best alternative so you know I'm making
rents as a professor if I'd be willing
to do this job for you know one-tenth
the salary and so then everything above
that one tenth of the of my current
salaries is rents okay that's it doesn't
like it sounds like a bizarre right
rules already yes so that and it's but
it's not it's not completely alien to
the traditional use of like payments for
land because the idea was that an
opportunity cost of land is zero it just
sits there and so and so that's why
landlords are like often you know the
worst people in history it's like why
they're like that it's just like like
yeah you're and why they've often been
called like social parasites is that
you're just there's a pure landlord and
pure form is just sitting there
collecting rent while like the land that
they owned purely by virtue of a
property right doesn't actually Jen
they're not actually doing anything to
produce that value and you can imagine
the real world developing and doing
stuff but that's not the pure landlord
function that's like it's gonna say like
that I mean just be fair if there's any
landlords in fact my friend Karen
listening out there you know like of
course real world people are often much
better than just sitting in their home I
think conceptually you can split apart
the like it's a different way the the
maintain the development and maintenance
of a house with ownership rights of the
land on top of that house yeah
and so you know and so that's why it's
like the opportunity cost of land pure
land was zero and so all the payments
going to land were considered rent and
somehow it's but it's but it's become a
way of conceptualizing a certain kind of
bad behavior under capitalism or assert
a certain way it doesn't work and well
sometimes use that way I mean I think in
core in this textbook project what we
try to say is that you know there's
productive and an entrepreneur starting
a new business seeing that there's like
some service that could be offered
that's not being offered and starting a
business to do that there rent-seeking
but that's but because there's like a
rent there that's like a
between what the things that are that
that person's time and the cost of those
materials and all that and what they
could be getting by producing this good
and selling it so they're getting a rent
by supplying this market okay thing it
doesn't sound like such a bad friend
seeking it like a lot of innovation and
a lot of entrepreneurship is in fact
chasing rents too as a part of making
the market work and that's part of how
markets work is that people inside the
market are like chasing rents all over
the place and trying to meet people's
needs and and lower costs and things
like that and so there's a very so I
don't we shouldn't prejudice the term
rent seeking as necessarily a bad thing
although I think when it is used in a
prejudiced way it's often referred to
kind of like artificially raising
barriers to entry
you know like engaging in the kind of
activities that are like zero-sum so
that you're like trying to like raise
your share of a pie at the expense of
someone else's rather than trying to
grow a pie but I think that's that's how
it's used in a pejorative way but I
think conceptually we can sort of say
it's just like trying to get something
they're trying to get a flow of income
that's higher than your opportunity cost
and just to put a pin in it that
opportunity cost is a pretty
metaphysical idea so it's very high so
it's a it's it's um it's you know we say
it we say rents very casually but
actually operationalizing what's a rent
and what isn't is well I mean this is an
issue I think this issue in physics as
well where we used words like energy and
dimension and time in a different way
than people use them on the street in
economics we also were use words and and
struggle over their definitions there's
a very related word I wanted to get to
that I know you and other people were
feisty about on Twitter recently namely
neoliberalism uh-huh and of course it's
it's liberalism then it's neo and I
think that maybe it goes back to Reagan
and Thatcher era things but some people
use it to mean Bill Clinton and Tony
Blair yeah some people just use the
ketene everything good or everything bad
so I find as a very clear statement of
it as a 1950 article by Milton Friedman
where he actually just literally
explains what the
neoliberalism is and it's not
libertarianism importantly it is not
just librarian ISM will be the more pure
free market more pure free market no
need for a state even yeah like we don't
even need police freaking like well so I
think I think the Nightwatchman state
might be on the outer edges of
neoliberalism and but then you know in
Milton Friedman's article he really does
talk about like the functions of
government should be to not distort the
market and but that that also means that
it needs to provide like antitrust and
and might need to do some sort of basic
income provision and so that's why I
like a ubi like the universal basically
yeah so I don't think he uses the term
but I think he's he's he's not unopposed
to the idea that the government's doing
some non distortionary redistribution
but what Milton Friedman radical leftist
well yes but I think it's very important
and this is sort of where we're started
with with that like econ one oh three in
econ 104 is that the the the broad view
of neoliberalism is like the open
markets is just like of free money and
and it's just always like going to be a
it's both good for prosperity it's fair
on its own rights like what you get in
the market is pretty close to what you
might deserve yeah and and we might need
to fix it like with these very
particular tools like we might need to
in some places make it a little bit more
competitive or I might need to undo the
worst successes of it by by by by
redistributing to the poor but the idea
that you would like broadly have to have
the government intervene in a variety of
places inside the economy was like
they're like no and in you know so in
particular like you know regulations and
things like that we're in like seeing is
not not particularly necessary because
you know the market would would fix it
but I guess
yeah I'm still a little unclear in this
way yeah so and so I don't think that
the word each should even be used
because people mean different things by
okay so let me give you I think a very
clear I think which is just this broad
confidence in markets as the baseline
mechanism for
organizing the production of but I'm
gonna get that if the government passes
a rule that you know is sort of a safety
standards for factory yes
does that distort the market yes so
exclaims yeah so like I mean imagine
ridiculous trying to contrast that with
like literal central planning that says
you know here is the cost of this good
yep so so soda but you know because we
can come up with ridiculous regulations
and then and and so there's some
regulations that that so you know a good
example is zoning restrictions in
California that's where you know endless
numbers of people have pointed out how
like these restrictions on where and
what you can build are causing all these
other problems and so you know there's a
very neoliberal take to them take on
that which is like get rid of them and
then there's like a less confident and
less articulate thing which is that well
some of them might be there for a reason
and we can't just necessarily presume
that they're all bad because there are
restrictions on markets that there's
some restrictions on markets that are in
fact good even though they are
distorting and even though they are like
deviations from this from you know some
sort of a more efficient benchmark
because of either the kinds of
communities that they support because of
the political coalition's they allow
because of something else potentially
non-economic and that that's that's a
that's a that's a an argument that we
can have is you know so if I maybe I'm
yeah beginning to get it in the sense
that something like a safety regulation
a rezoning restriction counts as a
distortion of the market because it's
saying here's something you can't do in
the mark here some in here's some
voluntary mutually improving transaction
that we the government will say that you
cannot do right because I could build a
you know really really does the factory
and people might want to work in it and
the government saying you can't do that
yeah okay yep and you know my favorite
sister come back to it it's like my
favorite example of like a bit of the
Constitution that like rules out some of
this is actually the Thirteenth
Amendment which says that you were I'm
literally not allowed to
to myself I cannot unwillingly even
though I might be that was very
conscious at the time because there was
like Mexican peons in New Mexico in in
the New Mexico Territory that were in
debt bondage and you know that was one
of the things I was coming up was like
are they covered under the 13 them
because they'd voluntarily yeah so you
have issues with neoliberalism yeah I
guess so I think it's also like kind of
one of these things that way past the
sell-by date and it's it was also just
like when I just think of the origins of
so many of the kind of social problems
that we've got now I just feels in my
like it just feels like the history is
kind of borne out that a lot of those
can be laid at the feet of policy
reforms that were conducted in the name
of neoliberalism in the in the 70s 80s
and 90s and even in through the up and
through the Bush and Obama
administrations so that's why that
ideological label is some people see it
as so elastic but some people say is
like no there was a real tendency and a
real commonality that went through all
of those administrations
and this is the name that we give to it
and you know one of the things this is
just my physics prejudice showing
through but one of the things that
fascinates me is the relationship of
various economic doctrines capitalism
and Neel ISM neoliberalism for example
to time right and one of the big counter
arguments against neoliberalism or
capitalism maybe is that it is led to
disastrous of climate change because of
tragedy of the Commons kind of kind of
things and we need to move beyond this
sort of just adjust to what the market
wants if we're going to serve future
generations but then then there's a big
philosophy question like on the one hand
how much do we owe to future generations
and on the other hand a previous guest
Astro Taylor brought brings up this
question of why do we pay so much
attention to the wishes of previous
generation how and people you know have
their wills that are distributed in
certain ways or inheritances and yeah
and is there is there a way that has
this been properly theorized the
relationship of economics to future and
past generations so there has been a lot
of theory
about you know so here's an intuition
from economics that probably other
people haven't thought of is that one of
the things that you also get is that
future generations are also going to be
richer than us just because of
technological change and what hopes yes
yeah yeah and so so for any given level
of climate change you you know there's
some ways in which like future
generations there might be actually
better off might have more tools to deal
with it or in any case might be richer
and so some I mean I'm not gonna I don't
necessarily think this but there's
there's there's there's there's some
arguments for saying that if you are
going to do this trade offs across
generations you might want to also take
account of the kind of income inequality
across generations because we are poorer
than our future than future generations
are going to be so maybe we've earned a
little right to put a headset unless we
destroy the planet or another planet so
that's you know so that's like the
that's a it's a good that you said that
because it puts a finger on like a real
deficiency of the way economists think
about things which is that we're always
thinking in terms of like smooth
optimization problems yeah and so
there's like oh there's always some
margin on which you could like shift a
little bit more here versus there but if
you're dealing with these systems that
have these big nonlinearities and cliffs
and things like that then that kind of
like thinking at the margin that
economists are kind of trained to do
doesn't work super well is less
appropriate yeah and so that's I think
like a pretty deep I think criticism of
economics is that this this like really
focus on thinking about what you can do
at the margin where you have these kind
of you can always move a little bit from
choice a to choice B and so you just
have to pick in between them fails when
you're just like nope it's like a big
gap in in past and so you need some
other decision calculus - well yeah I
mean that's the opposite of I guess
Tyler Cowen was a previous guest on a
podcast and he has this point of view
that the best thing to do the morally
best action is just to maximize economic
growth
yeah because compound interest right you
know it catches up and also we should
not discount future generations at all
there are people just like us I made him
slightly disgruntled by calling him the
temporal version of Peter Singer hi
a faraway I guess my Jenny's counting
future people but I I think it makes
sense to me to discount future
generations because of such so much
uncertainty about what things will be
like like what how can we possibly think
that we're accurately judging what the
future generations are going to have or
not have yeah so I think the uncertainty
in makes this complicated and but you
know then you get into these like insane
kind of calculations that effective
altruism people kind of do of like the
risk of AI yeah
so you basically what about the future
I'm sorry
they're insane but we also have to do
them and so we do have to do them but I
think the idea that you can it feels
like you're a lot of doing a lot of like
division by small numbers and so you can
make quantity small quantities blow up
by dividing by like a really really
small number and you're supplying really
big numbers by really small yes any
number you want right so so you're
you're in that space with a lot of these
future discounting calculations is so
it's just it feels like again the tools
of like trying to think about the
trade-offs aren't really well-suited to
that because the scales are just like up
in the air which oh we just have no idea
what the magnitudes are so like thinking
quantitatively about trade-offs at you
know ten generations from now I'm not
sure it's super productive yeah so I get
I take your point that there's sort of
an attitude that says that future
generations will on the one hand be
better equipped on the other hand know
more about what the situation is so
maybe they should but I also think it's
moot for climate change like we really
exactly like we are here already
like yeah I'm like my life is materially
worse because of climate change it's
like oh yeah yeah so so I feel like all
this like oh how much we wait the
generations of the future it's done that
was the 15 years ago conversation and
okay but I like the I like still the
analogy of inequality of you know the
present to the future because you know
so let's go back to the present and
there's inequality now and this has been
a long-standing thing among economists
right you know they measure progress by
GDP or something like that and less by
how the worst off people are doing is
there more am I crazy and thinking there
seems to be more
attention now paid to issues of
inequality yeah absolutely I mean
absolutely in a Nobel laureate and my
first year of grad school 2004 at
Berkeley I went like I'm interested in
studying inequality and he was very
smart he said he's like ah you know
nobody really cares about studying
inequality except the French the French
really like studying inequality and he
was absolutely right but one of those
things and and and so but I think
obviously that's changed I think Occupy
Wall Street by the roll I think Bernie
Sanders I think the actual just
continuing increase of inequality has
been its own work so so and so and I
think one of the one of the sorry go
ahead
let's not let go let that go by too
quickly it is fairly agreed upon that in
the last some number of years and maybe
you should tell me rather than guessing
inequality has been increasing ya know I
think nobody can deny that inequality is
increased over the last like 40 years
yeah in like people are yeah in the u.s.
in the UK in almost everywhere although
the magnitude of the increase is much
muted in the continental countries the
people will argue but exactly how much
and like you can there are calculations
you can do that kind of get you a range
that is looks like Oh wasn't so bad or
it was enormous but it's blowing up more
in the more liberal countries yes it has
gotten out more in the more Anglo
countries almost for sure it's also got
up a lot though in developing countries
so countries that have grown a lot like
a neoliberal country yeah yeah so so
yeah so that yes I think that's that and
so one of the interesting I think recent
areas of research is the stuff pursued
by Paquette II and Saez and zucman
that's kind of come out of that whole
French research program which is the
idea of distributional national accounts
which is that instead of just keeping
track of like the aggregate GDP of a
country let's keep track of it by
percentile and so then you get an easy
statistic it's just look at median GDP
instead of like mean median will just
get you like pretty much the sense in
which the 50th
percentile is doing and that's like a
not a bad proxy for also capturing how
evenly distributed the growth is and
it's a nice kind of marketing ploy
because no one can argue with collecting
more data or no more data well people
can argue like a normative so you
because like again just like it comes in
with the national accounts you can a lot
of folk theory goes into the
construction of the measures and so you
have to argue a lot on both some people
are arguing about what are the folk
theories that are going into
constructing these statistics and so
that's where there's like an active
argument on Twitter and things like that
and so so choosing what to pay attention
to is a big choice and yeah yeah exactly
it's a yeah and what assumptions you
make about allocating dollars and things
that's gets into the weeds in that okay
but anyway inequalities increasing yep
probably we should do something about
that I mean I guess people's opinions
will differ
lots of people think like now we didn't
do anything but in equality we should
just fix poverty um lots of people think
that what do you think I think you don't
get you don't get a flourishing society
with like insane amounts of inequality
let's just again lay it out there you
know there's certainly I think that my
youthful self would have been guilty of
saying look if everyone is better off it
doesn't matter that some people are way
better off it's still better right yeah
so is there an intrinsic value to it I
just think there's lots of things in
there's lots of dimensions of things
that are important that are in fact
zero-sum and so when you have this kind
of like it's things even if just
something very bit like relative status
in society is basically kind of a thing
that you because it's relative it's
gotta be zero-sum and so when you have
enormous income inequality and it's
roughly correlate with this it means
that some people have very low status
and that's just not great for like a
good healthy democratic society and and
so that's it that's that's itself is
like a reason once you have some things
that are zero-sum that are correlated
with they come along with income
inequality that's a good reason to
reduce the income inequality and so that
those zero-sum things can include
relative status they can include
political power they can include like
cultural representation in society
there's a bunch of things that are not
just expanding the pie but where the
distribution of the pie really like
means that some people are made worse
off and is the solution to this as
simple as changing the tax code wealth
taxes or inheritance taxes or just a
more progressive texts I hope so because
the only other thing is like we either
do it through policy like here's the bet
is that the only way in which we've seen
the quality of this type like fall in
the past is with like social
catastrophes okay and like it's either
an internal revolution or its external
war or I mean Walter Schneider was the
book this great level the great level or
that kind of makes this point but here's
the here's the bet which is that we are
progressed enough as a society as a
civilization we have enough tools of
government and enough tools of reason in
the society that we can actually use
policy to reduce inequality without
having to go through a war right that's
free yeah that's the a that's that's the
and that's one of the reasons for like
thinking about the the goals is like a
wealth tax and these things is like look
guys we don't have to you know worry
about millions of dead people we if we
can actually get these like relatively
mild policy things into play and you can
imagine the same someone with climate
change it's like you know one way or
another like the the climate is gonna
like fix us but the human brain just
isn't meant to think to reason on these
timescales right I mean if someone is
very wealthy right now and has never
seen a revolution in their lifetime that
prospect just doesn't seem real to them
right and so maybe it's for their own
good that we'll take it from them
but you know I think that's the thing
it's like yeah they will fight it and
hopefully the idea is that if that doing
it through the democratic process is a
way to get it peacefully to do it like
while maintaining democratic
institutions and so I mean we've
certainly seen the
eyes grow wide among the cohort of
wealthy Democratic donors at the
prospect that Elizabeth Warren could get
nominated and start taxing their wealth
yeah and I mean good it's good I mean I
think it's a they someone said on
Twitter you know if the rest of us had
as much class solidarity as the
billionaires do they call each other on
the phone and tell you exactly yeah so
so I'm not not a and you know one of the
great so one of the things about the
wealth inequality thing that I think
Paquette II and others have sort of made
an apparent is that which is actually
something I learned it's sent fans to do
a long time ago which is this idea of
like like Gibran's will offer wealth
that like basically because assets have
these like stochastic multiplicative
returns so they just kind of grow at a
random rate that that can get you like
an extremely skewed like power-law
distribution of wealth and and so these
these power laws are just very natural
outcomes that sort of network processes
building let me yeah if the cumulative
processes yeah yeah I think and and that
explains why like a good old revolution
is the best way or you can think that
what you do is you damp down the growth
parameter and so you're like kind of
you're never gonna get rid of it but you
can like slow by taxing the rate of or
by taxing wealth you're kind of curbing
that growth that's happening every year
and sort of letting you know it'll still
like get out into like a power law but
just the thinness of the tail will be
less it's okay so the the sales pitch to
the wealthy donors is you'd rather have
the wealth tax than the guillotine yeah
I mean I think they know that at some
level I think at another level they're
like this isn't the society they
themselves grew up in yeah and I think
they feel some you know some of them at
least feel it might feel some guilt for
that I mean at a more practical level do
you have a favorite strategy maybe
wealth taxes serve some purpose but
there's other things to do oh yeah I
mean I'm like I said earlier I think
something like the the the labor
movement has to come back and both for
political reasons because it was a way
for so many regular people to
have their voices aggregated to express
be expressed politically that it trained
so many working-class people to like run
for office it was just like this
broad-based kind of institution that
when in the 50s had 35% of the American
workforce in it that just did a lot till
I compress the income distribution I
think when I think of what I'm sort of
like committed to is trying to figure
out how to use social science and things
to help sort of resuscitate something
that looks like at a labor movement are
you personally in favor of a basic
income I think not really actually I
mean it's an interesting idea to play
with I I wouldn't be opposed if we got
it but I do think there's a way in which
we all a see a lot of the gains and done
by like monopoly pricing and secondly
that there's like a real sense in which
work and like the fact of having to go
and interact productively with people
that are not like you is just like a
real great glue for don't you think I
mean I I'm completely open to this
possibility am i my mind is very open
about ubi and I'm glad that certain
local jurisdictions are experimenting
with it collect the data right but I
think almost everyone will still work
yeah that might be in which case then
well but and so I think that's fine I
mean then it just becomes like a it's
not actually a transformation of society
in any way well it's just like a little
extra cash you raise the floor for the
people who don't you raise the floor but
if you're not raising the floor enough
to get some people to like opt out of
the way to get you know some people opt
out then you're not raising the floor
that much yeah so I'm thinking of people
on Skid Row in Los Angeles yeah but you
know who could afford a studio apartment
if there were so yep um I think I think
there's a lot of that I I also would you
know my optimist outside will also think
that a lot of the other pathologies and
like pain that comes with being poor
would be less if you were just less poor
and
not a not a bad not a bad idea and
expensive um yeah it's not that I mean
you could do a ubi you know maybe not
like this
this year but like in ten years American
society could easily afford like a
reasonable ubi in fact there's a very
easy ways to do it right now which is
just take the Earned Income Tax Credit
that we already do and then just like
somewhere around eBay proposed this it
was just like make it so that it you
don't get zero if you're not working
you're just getting some positive amount
but then if you work more you get even
more by the EITC and so then that
disincentivizes like then people get a
basic income but there's still some
additional to work and so that might
actually be both the kind of the best of
both worlds yeah okay all right I want
to where it's time to wrap up I want to
give you an opportunity to promote at
least two different things one is the
idea of economics for inclusive
prosperity yeah I get that right yep
so here the idea of that was we me and
Dani Rodrik and gabriel zucman were at a
conference with intellectual historians
and sociologists was that caspase at
Stanford and it was a kind of about in
your liberalism and all of these other
social sciences were like economics was
is responsible for neoliberalism and we
were like what are you talking about and
and basically so we started this
initiative to kind of just collect
policy ideas and get like a group of
economists that we're kind of doing
progressive policy that were kind of
doing work in progressive policy circles
but um it we just wasn't getting heard
in either policymakers or even other
social sciences and so we're like let's
put up this flag that's just suggest
that there is in fact like at least a
community of economists that are non
neoliberal and good branding goes along
with a good branding and and see what
comes up and so that was kind of our and
we've gotten some really I mean some of
the policy memos are really fantastic
people and it's also giving people like
economists that have really great ideas
that started what is it was it mean it
starts a prosperity
oh I mean it's a it's a generic nice
thing it's like who could be against
inclusive prosperity yeah but but the
idea that like the
I'm a growth it's not enough to just
consider the level economic growth you
also want to consider it's okay
distribution and you don't just want to
consider like economic economic growth
narrowly as GDP you want to consider the
broad measures of human flourishing yeah
yeah but yeah and the price of entry is
kind of one of these like five to 10
page policy memos that kind of like you
builds on your research or something
you've worked on and sort of talks about
like a idea for either a policymaker to
run with or just kind of a view on a way
to make the world better and so these
these these policy briefs that we have
come back you've been kind of really
fantastic and really really interesting
so I just encourage everyone to go check
it out at econ fit dot org all right we
will link to it on the show notes okay
the other thing you added me today well
sorry before before I'm going the other
thing it does remind me I wanted to just
ask a little bit about the duty that you
have as a social scientist or any
economist in particular I mean there was
just a conference in Santa Fe I don't
know if you were there now yeah it
seemed to be from the live tweeting
there seem to be a lot of ragging on
economists on the basis of a bending
their social responsibilities you know
Jeffrey West said like why aren't
economists leading the battle against
climate change and so I I've always
thought that it's perfectly okay to be a
scientist even a social scientist who
just tries to describe what happens in
the world but it's also okay as a field
there might be an obligation to
intervene constructively in some ways so
what is it okay so what's the social
obligation of economists well I don't
know I mean you think that there is one
I mean do you think that if you have if
do no harm would be a good I mean I
guess the the argument I buy is that
there are experts who have a certain
kind of special expertise and if it's
clear that that particular kind of
expertise could be deployed to make the
world a better place that at least some
fraction of people who have that
expertise should do that yes I think I
think that's true
and I think that does happen I mean I
think you'll find that economists are
much more involved in policymaking than
almost any other social science set and
and some of them are I think like real
like working on climate it like my
colleagues here work on climate change
all the time i I don't know that we have
more of a responsibility than physicists
and ya know actually needed why I think
that you know the the philosophy that I
just outlined which is and I don't
necessarily hold very strongly I'm just
trying to figure it out myself but I
think that for the most part academics
intellectuals scholars should try to say
true things about the world but they're
you know that's right next to doing good
things in the world and I admit that
there's a connection there I would be
sick I would be happy if we just
restricted ourselves to saying true
things about the world like so so I mean
it's partly that the field has been so
is is has been like it's ideologically
driven in a way leave most fields are
not partly is ideological Riven because
there's actual conservatives in
economics in the way that there aren't
in lots of other fields and so there are
actually like political disagreements
and they're often it so I have a paper
on this how like you can actually
predict using the language of an
academic article you can like do a
pretty good job of predicting someone's
campaign contributions and in economics
because there's does it really reveals
for their values it yeah so there's like
ends and and so you're going to have
people with diverging values inside the
same discipline and I don't know that
the discipline should say like no
everybody should be doing when you you
know if you have these divergent values
and y'all disagreements over things well
but I mean the valence goes either way
like if someone legitimately believes
that there's something would make the
world a better place the question is
then you know whatever they that thing
is that they think would make the world
a better place is there some obligation
to do it I don't think there's a sort of
individual level obligation but maybe
there is a discipline wide obligation
yeah so I think if the discipline agreed
on what those things were look I would
it would be a discuss but I don't know
that we agree and the other thing was
you mentioned a textbook oh yes so so
I'm part of this big of mian samples and
others and many other people in the
circle of Santa Fe of the Senna
Institute have been for a long time
involved in a textbook project called
core score - econ org and it's basically
a big online open source textbook that's
not just like a usual way of teaching
it's it's aimed to be an introduction to
economics textbook but it really sort of
presents introductory economics in a way
that's really different from every other
textbook and every other textbook is
kind of the same to each other and so
and what we're really trying to do is
trying to say that like economics is not
just supplying - it's not just the
frictionless model and so how we try to
teach it and Simon did a Oh another SFI
person drew the analogy that core is
kind of - traditional economics with the
Fineman lecturers were - like the
physics teaching of the day which always
like yes - like a grab sort of the
things that are happening on the
research frontier and make them
intelligible and useful to like people
that are encountering it for the first
time the idea that if you're never gonna
take another economics class should you
think the world looks like the
frictionless model or should you get
this kind of like library of gadgets for
thinking about the world okay all right
that's good is it it's out it's online
its end and you can just go and look at
it you can order it from OUP from Oxford
University Press it's like a real book
always be online and for free but if you
also want it's a real books yeah all
right
Suresh I do thank you so much thank you
so much for having me okay
[Music]
you
[Music]